nowadays we often see articles claiming
at the top 1% is richer than ever before
and that wealth inequality must be
stopped while these conclusions are
based on facts they can still be
misleading over the past century the
richest have actually gotten poorer and
the poorest have gotten richer and on
top of this we have seen the creation of
a brand-new class the middle class so
here's why the average person's life
quality is better than ever before
[Music]
first of all let's address the point
that the richer are richer than ever
before this is really not true and is
largely influenced by inflation as was
economic growth we see a net worth of
100 billion dollars and think wow just
20 years ago the richest person couldn't
even crack half of that this must be
because the rich are getting richer on
the backs of everyone else but this is
just a classic case of relative versus
absolute difference in the last 20 years
the US GDP alone has over doubled while
the GDP s of many developing countries
grew exponentially increasing by factors
of 5 to 10 so in reality their wealth
simply grew with the economy take Rick
and Jeff for instance let's say Rick was
making $50,000 a year and Jeff was
making $200,000 a year at the beginning
of a time period and at the end let's
say Rick is making 100k while Jeff is
making 400 K both of their incomes
doubled and the percentage difference
between the two remains identical in
fact the extra 50k rika was probably
much more impactful to Rick's life than
the extra 200k Jeff got despite this
absolute difference would tell you that
the income inequality is vastly more at
the start Jeff made 150 thousand dollars
more than Rick but by the end
Jeff was making $300,000 more than Rick
does this mean that Rick is relatively
richer now no but that's what we would
often perceive this same principle
applies to the richest in society in
1937 Rockefeller had one point four
billion dollars let's just assume that
the average person has zero dollars
this means that back in the good old
days friendly John only had one point
four billion dollars more than the
average person but today greedy jeff has
147 billion more than the average person
the absolute difference between us and
them is larger than ever before but Jeff
is actually relatively much poorer than
John in today's dollars Rockefeller
would have 253 to 400 billion dollars
while Andrew Carnegie would have 310 to
two billion both of which are well over
double Jeff Bezos wealth going back much
further Augustus Caesar would have had
four point six trillion today so though
the wealth of the richest continues to
go up numerically relatively they're
actually losing wealth not only are they
losing wealth but her companies are
controlling less and less of the market
meaning that the control of monopolies
is also decreasing benefiting the
average person in the 1880s Rockefellers
Standard Oil Company controls 90% of the
refineries and pipelines in the u.s.
today the oil market has grown
internationally and the u.s. is a top
oil producing country but they only
control eighteen percent of the market
similarly the behemoths today control
are significantly less than what their
early counterparts controlled across all
industries moving on to the middle class
news articles often point out that
middle class wages have stagnated and
that the middle class is shrinking
here's the thing the Bureau of Labor
Statistics themselves
suggest that the per capita income is in
fact increasing even when adjusted for
inflation in 1967 the average dude made
sixteen thousand two hundred and forty
to two thousand eighteen dollars or just
a little bit above minimum wage in 2018
however the average dude made thirty six
thousand eighty dollars is there some
stagnation around the 2008 recession
sure but the overall trend is clearly
still going up and asked for the middle
class shrinking well unfortunately this
is actually true it pains me to say it
as a middle class has shrunk from fifty
three point two percent in 1967 to forty
two point one percent in 2016
unfortunately nowadays just too many
guys are ruthless ly moving on up
leaving the middle class in the dust in
all seriousness though the middle class
is shrinking but so are low income
households so more times than not these
guys are moving up not down not only
this but the average American household
is getting smaller
meaning more money per person
thereby significantly bigger houses as
well the median square foot per person
has nearly doubled since 1973 and the
average price per square foot is
basically the same over time when
adjusted for inflation so I say the
middle-class is doing just fine in fact
I'd say they're thriving as many of them
are moving up the same goes for
low-income households while there may
not be thriving with a middle-class
there's less of them than ever before
and that leaves us with a global poverty
people living in extreme poverty which
is defined as people living on less than
one dollar and ninety cents per day has
decreased from about 35 percent in 1987
to about 11 percent in 2013
most regions have actually done
exponentially better while one region
sub-saharan Africa does lag behind but
even there we can still see progress
from percentages in the 50s to
percentages in the 40s
similarly child mortality and death in
childbirth have seen substantial
decreases furthermore more people are
getting an education around the world
and that they're getting longer
education as well and likewise literacy
rates are through the roof evidently
every single income level has made
progress forward except for the
wealthiest of society sure their numbers
are higher but relatively they're the
only class as progressed but that's not
what's important anyways as the goal
isn't to bring down wealthy people their
goal is to improve the situation's of
the poorest people and the average
people in a country and the fact is the
average person is more educated makes
more money it's more independent and
overall has a much better life quality
than their parents who already had much
better life quality than their parents
and that's what's important as it shows
progress are some classes doing better
than others absolutely but does that
mean that other classes are doing bad of
course not so instead of trying to raise
taxes on the wealthy and trying them for
having so much money we should use them
as a reference to what's possible and
with that we simply try to improve our
situation from
parent situation and collectively doing
this will ensure that wealth inequality
will indefinitely continue to be better
than ever before but that's just what I
think if you guys agree then drop a like
and consider supremacy more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one